you see Tariq I've never met him I've
only heard a Pashtun elder you you bat
out yeah he's in the bay
he's yes okay maybe I'll just text me I
should train with him for no reason get
ready for just post corona world know
what I'm doing standard always that
character and say I want to work on my
high kicks that's all I want to work on
just tires and high kicks he's all
kisses really not my thing
I'm just trying the high kick man I just
want to do a high kicks yeah what was
that character he's Lance Lance can't
stop us when it's venomous dude like I
didn't do him for two years
like I just took that time off did you
ever see him do it no oh my god heard
about it done he's my wife beater right
or tank yeah yeah yeah Mohammad small
this prithi Oh like Lance predates
Theo's mom he's the first bullet post
80s first mullet at the Comedy Store
okay 100% yeah I did a documentary
called Lance can't stop was out of
nowhere it's on YouTube
so really it's like a 14 minute doc on
Lance I know some of the comedy store
[ __ ] dude your videos make me laugh so
hard
thanks man dude it's incredible how good
of a [ __ ] dancer you are you know
that's kind of a weird thing that it's
this or go back you know it's the second
one do ya know bear that here this is
the intro yeah here just play this
[Music]
the infra is really cool I think coming
to this worth of blank slate but you do
it that's laid up to you I made sure my
husband [ __ ] [ __ ] you're here really
like that no they were just it's a weave
so like whenever Lance is about to go up
I would like duck out into the back bar
the Comedy Store and I would like clip
these weaves into the back and then I
would have a wife beater underneath my
clothes I'm like Superman changing
before going on stage and then they
would announce me and then Lance would
just dance for like a minute up top and
just do Q&A this is so fun but yeah
Bobby's in the stock Neal Brennan zanuck
kumail's in it Mary Lynn Rajskub
Jeff Ross so like you know they'll like
we're cool enough to be in it
like I sought the other day I'm like oh
man I just I missed this place you know
God no [ __ ] yeah that's the intro but so
I didn't do them for two years people
were like oh where did you go how come
you don't do it anymore
that's the way I look so I actually did
it one time before this virus like came
I brought him back and then this hit you
did at the store yeah before everything
shut down and it was so fun dude yeah I
can't play it yeah you can't try to find
a standard clip like the one before it
or actually go to L can't stop us on
Instagram uses known as the in zone he
has his own IG hello can't stop with ya
I can't believe never seen him dance
some loser no I didn't know you could
dance you can actually dance I get for a
comedian I'm pretty did you see how he
danced what did not I just I was really
into Michael Jackson as a kid and my
joke is like I was good but luckily not
good enough to get it get on his radar
good enough for the neighborhood but not
good enough that he hears about it a
continent away
here's scroll down that bullet buddy
no [ __ ] here go down yeah play though
that one right there right there see
what that is about incest you know
here's your try different ones there's a
crowd work keep going that's dudu do you
have any children yourself like razor
amazing how there's nobody's smarter
than you membrane it'd be like 30 people
in the audience right yeah he would
always go on like a midnight train go
back to his profile [ __ ] dude can we
play this one number then I'll move on
to play the play play the one where he's
in the gene Jack there which have you
seen this one count no oh that's what
Melissa this is my friends I know I may
refresh other goes wait me folks this
one's so good I'll get off Instagram
page yeah we can show this right this is
yeah this is for Melissa was on us
the background of the other one well is
he
who is that the most at peace in your
love
[Music]
[Applause]
sket I got expelled me from being too
rebellious more travels fast so what you
like to live here now practice if you
want to be the best there's a whole
world of dance out there that you don't
even know about what it's such an 80s
vibe it's so it's really well shot
yeah eres no no Aristotle like the
theorists see the stand-up ended
director and really so good yeah really
good who is he Aristotle so he was he's
in goat face like we started doing
videos together and like he could do so
much with no money
like this is just YouTube days oh my god
okay
okay these dancers yeah I wanted to do
an homage like break-in and like all
those 80s dance move
[Music]
this is such an Amy's vibe right it
looks like a terrible eighties movie and
check-check example so the money I have
and just have $30 take it all right keep
your necklace leave us alone
we couldn't get a fake light we only had
one shot at it the whole point is like
those movies I would grow up watching
them you know and they oh yeah they
would always it was almost like who's
these white characters who are the
central characters yeah I'm gonna take
you to the inner city show you how they
do it here yeah and it's like they were
just like visiting like it's a zoo or
something then they would go back to
their white lives be like check it out I
know I know the black yeah true so I
wanted to recreate that but then show
how removed they are from that world
where like they're having a good time
but he's afraid of like the people he's
dancing with really well shot yeah
Ariston was great so like it was a great
partnership because I would do a lot of
videos on my own before I met him just
the ideas were always there it's very
DIY and he always loved them and he was
like oh I'm a pretty good I do videos
and stuff but I he didn't have any body
of work he stopped doing it for a long
time
Wow yeah he's in LA
he's like my UCB he's like in Franklin
Village yeah so like doing he's doing
this he's doing directing and comedy and
writing and stuff full-time but this is
when we were uh Turing around you know
like runts and he liked my stuff and he
was like if I direct and you write and
then we just started making some magic
together that's cool man yeah that's
cool you've doubled down on video since
quarantine you know what's crazy is like
sometimes when you think about your
career and stuff it's all happenstance
like I didn't design it like this but
when stand-up was going on I would do a
lot of stand-up and I would do some
sketch when I had an idea on IG but now
this is all there is this is my only
stage yeah so I've just been like going
harder on this cuz that's it kind of
takes the guesswork out of how to split
your time yeah and the response has been
pretty good yeah thanks man no I'll come
over yeah I'll do it camión I was gonna
turn my house into a studio like it's
paramount law and price
why mask it's the most low-rent sketch
of [ __ ] ham in the corner I'm tell
you this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]